LARA GOOD AFTERNOON EVERYONE
LIKE.
CALLED AGING A LONG TERM CARE
COMMITTEE TO ORDER.
AND.
WELL.
KALRA.
HERE.
PROPEL.
CABALLERO.
GIPSON.
GLORIA.
MELENDEZ.
RUBIO HERE.
UNLESS WE HAVE WE DO HAVE A
QUORUM.
AND WELCOME EVERYONE TO OUR
FIRST HEARING OF THE AND I JUST
WANT TO START. BY WELCOMING A
TWO NEW COMMITTEE MEMBERS WERE
I'M VERY HAPPY TO HAVE WITH US
THE SAME NUMBER RUBIO AND
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MELENDEZ SO
WELCOME. ADD TO BOTH YOU AND AND
I'M VERY HAPPY AGAIN TO HAVE YOU
WITH US.
I I KNOW WHAT I WAS TOLD THERE'S
GONNA BE BALLOONS QUE CAN C#M
THAT HE AND I AM. CURRENTLY WHAT
IS BYOB HEAVY ON BALLOONS YEAH
HOW WE GOT.
WHATABURGER APPROVAL COMMITTEE.
AND AND I AND I JUST WANT ALSO
MENTION ONE OTHER THING.
I WANNA THINK.
BERRY IRENE AND AND THE MEMBERS
THAT WERE ABLE TO PARTICIPATE
DURING THE FALL A WE HAD THREE
INFORMATIONAL HEARINGS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE ONE AND
SANDALS AND NUMBER OF YOU WERE
THERE AS WELL.
AND THE AUDIENCE LOVE THE
STAKEHOLDERS WERE THERE.
WE HAVE ONE IN SAN JOSE WE HAD
ONE IN SAN DIEGO ONE LOS ANGELES
I IN PARTICULAR.
SIMMER GLORIA AND HIS TEAM ARE
VERY áP HELPFUL.
IN THEM OF THIS AND THE SAN
DIEGO MEETING AND A SUMMARY
GIPSON.
AND HIS TEAM WERE VERY HELPFUL
IN THE LOS ANGELES MEETING AND I
THINK WE LEARNED A LOT. I THINK
THAT WE'RE GOING TO SEE THAT I
LEARNED A LOT I THINK
WAS GREAT TO CONNECT THE NETWORK
OF ADVOCATES UP AROUND AND
POLICY MAKERS AROUND THE STATE.
WHILE WE WERE ON OUR DOWN TIME
LEGISLATIVE CYCLE AND I THINK IT
PUTS ALL OF US IN A MUCH BETTER
POSITION. TO ADVOCATE AND PUT
AS WE ENSURING TO TWENTY
EIGHTEEN. AND THAT'S PART OF WHY
WE'RE HERE TODAY BUT AS WE HAVE
A BILL BEFORE US TODAY.
IN SO IF ANYONE OUT ZERO ONE OF
A ARE LIVING IN NEW MEMBERS ONE
ANALYSTS SAY BESIDES THE FACT
THEY'RE DISAPPOINTED UP THAT
THERE ARE BALLOONS BUT I HAVE
NOT. I JUST I'M THANK YOU I LOOK
FORWARD TO TO WORKING WITH ALL
OF YOU I AM.
IN HUMAN SERVICES AND SO
THERE'S A NATURAL CONNECTION TO
TO THIS COMMITTEE SADDAM HOPING
TO MERGE BOTH.
POLICIES AND HOPEFULLY WE CAN
ACCOMPLISH A LOT THROUGHPUT
COMMITTEES AND.
JUST LOOK FOR TO TO WORKING
WITH YOU THIS YEAR.
WHAT WHAT I THINK YOU ALSO
MOTHERS SO MUCH SUMMER
MAIENSCHEIN HAS AB FIFTEEN
HUNDRED SO TO ADMINISTER THE
PROGRAM?
AND MISTER CHAIRMAN I ALSO
WANNA THANK YOU AND YOUR STAFF
OF FOR YOUR EXCELLENT WORK WITH
MY OFFICE ON THIS AS WELL. AB
FIFTEEN HUNDRED WHAT ENACT THE
ELDERS LIVING WITH DIGNITY
APATHY RESPECT AND SUPPORT BOND
ACT WHICH WILL PROVIDE FOR A
BOND ISSUE OF TWENTY MILLION
DOLLARS FOR CONSTRUCTION AND OR
RENOVATION OF THE DAYCARE
FACILITIES FOR INDIVIDUALS WITH
ALZHEIMER'S DEMENTIA. OR RELATED
MEMORY DISORDERS FOLLOWING THE
TWO THOUSAND EIGHT RECESSION
CALIFORNIANS HAVE SUFFERED THE
CLOSURE OF DOZENS OF HOME AND
COMMUNITY BASED SETTING
SPECIFICALLY DESIGNED TO SERVE
THE UNIQUE NEEDS OF PERSONS.
WITH DEMENTIA AND THEIR FAMILY
CAREGIVERS WHILE CALIFORNIA'S
PROJECTED SENIOR POPULATION IS
GROWING AT AN ASTOUNDING RATE
THE COMMUNITY BASED SERVICES FOR
THE ELDERLY HAVE BEEN
SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCED IN MANY
CASES IN ORDER TO OPEN OUR
CONTINUE THE OPERATION OF THESE
DAYCARE PROGRAMS. FOR THE FRAIL
ELDERLY THE COST OF START UP
CONSTRUCTION RENOVATION.
OR EQUIPMENT REPLACEMENT
CONSTITUTES THE PRIMARY BARRIER
TO CONTINUING OR EXPANDING THESE
VALUABLE SERVICES.
THIS MEASURE WILL HELP TO MEET
THE NEEDS OF THE GROWING SENIOR
POPULATION WITH SPECIAL EMPHASIS
ON THE FRAIL ELDERLY. IT WILL
ALLOW INDIVIDUALS TO REMAIN IN
THEIR HOMES LONGER PRESERVING
THEIR DIGNITY AND QUALITY OF
LIFE WHILE ALSO INVOICE MEAN
SIGNIFICANTLY MORE COSTLY
INSTITUTIONALIZE ATION. HERE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB FIFTEEN
HUNDRED A BACKING MARQUEZ AND
DON MYERS PERKY DIRECTOR OF THE
YELLOW ADULT DAYCARE. CENTER.
AND SUSAN.
DAY. TOMORROW.
MY LESSONS MAIN SHINES I GUESS A
LITTLE YEAH WELL AROUND ON THESE
WITH ALZHEIMER ASSOCIATION. OF
COURSE NOT AGREEMENT LYDIA
MASALA THIS WEB. I GOTTA MARON
BANDS
WITH CALIFORNIA EVERYONE
INTRODUCES THE FIRST NAME I NINE
IN THAT.
WITH CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION FOR
ADULT DAY SERVICES CO SPONSOR
BABY FIFTEEN HUNDRED AND THEY'RE
HERE FOR TECHNICAL.
THANK YOU.
WITNESSES AND SPLIT UP GOOD
AFTERNOON.
I'M DAWN.
MYERS PERKY FOR THE EASIEST OF
ALL THE NAMES.
I AM PROGRAM DIRECTORY ALL
ADULT DAY HEALTH CENTER IT'S IN
WOODLAND.
IN THIS IS MY TWENTY SECOND
HERE AS THE PROGRAM DIRECTOR
I'VE DEDICATED MY CAREER TO
ADULT DAY SERVICES BECAUSE WHEN
I DISCOVERED.
THE PROGRAM AS A GERIATRIC
SOCIAL WORKER THIRTY YEARS AGO I
KNEW THIS COMMUNITY BASED NON
INSTITUTIONAL MODEL OF CARE
WOULD TRANSFORM LONG TERM CARE.
AND WANT TO CLEARLY UNDERSTAND
THE MODEL YOU REALIZE THAT
EVERYBODY IS THE WINNER WITH
ADULT DAY PROGRAMS.
INDIVIDUALS ARE WINNERS AND
THEY'RE SUPPORTED WHILE STILL
LIVING AT HOME THE CENTER BASED
INTERDISCIPLINARY TEAM WORKS
WITH THE PERSON. ON AN AVERAGE
OF THREE DAYS A WEEK AT THIS
FREQUENCY IS THE KEY TO MANAGING
THE DAY SERVICES OF THIS FRAIL
POPULATION WHO GENERALLY HAVE
OVER TEN CHRONIC DIAGNOSIS WITH
JUST AS MANY MEDICATIONS IF NOT
MORE. AND OF COURSE THE ADDED
BONUS IS THAT THE PARTICIPANT IS
ENGAGE SOCIALLY NOT ISOLATED
WHICH HAS A HUGE IMPACT ON THEIR
DEPRESSION IN THEIR STATE OF
MIND.
THE SECOND BIG WINNERS THE
FAMILY CAREGIVERS.
YOU KNOW IT FAMILY CAREGIVERS
ARE THE KEY PROVIDERS FOR CARE
FOR OUR LOVED ONES IN HEAVY HAVE
THE SUPPORT THEY NEED TO KEEP
THEIR LOVED ONE AT HOME AND THEY
TO NOW HAVE AN ACCESSIBLE
SUPPORT TEAM. THAT CAN ALWAYS BE
FOUND AT THE CENTER.
OTHER WINNERS OF THE PAIRS
WHETHER IT'S MEDI CAL THE V. A
LONG TERM CARE INSURANCE
EMPLOYERS OR INDIVIDUALS.
WOULD PAY SIGNIFICANTLY MORE FOR
IN HOME CARE ASSISTED LIVING ARE
CFU NURSING HOMES PLUS THE SAME
PAIR. SAVED EVEN MORE WHEN THE
PATIENT HAS REDUCE NEED FOR
EMERGENCY ROOM VISITS HOSPITAL
DAYS NURSING HOME STAYS DOCTORS
VISITS NUMBER OF MEDICATIONS
PRESCRIBED. NOT TO MENTION THAT
WORKING CAREGIVERS CAN GET BACK
TO WORK THESE ARE ALL DOCUMENTED
OUTCOMES.
AND THE FOURTH WIENER ARE THE
EMPLOYEES EMPLOYEES OF DAY
PROGRAMS LOVE THEIR JOBS AND
STAFF TURNOVER IS VERY LOW AND
THAT MEANS PROGRAMS CAN FOCUS ON
PASSIONATE LEADERSHIP. QUALITY
CARE REGULATORY COMPLIANCE
ADVANCED TRAINING CLINICAL
OUTCOMES IN INNOVATION.
WITH THE EVER INCREASING
PRESENCE OF MANAGED CARE COUPLED
WITH A STAGGERING DEMOGRAPHICS
OF THE ISOLATED FRAIL ELDERS
FAMILIES AND DOCTORS OFFICES ARE
CALLING IN REFERRING TO CENTERS
AT AN INCREASING RATE. AND
FINDING CENTERS ARE OPERATING AT
FULL CAPACITY OR THERE ARE NONE
IN THEIR COMMUNITIES AT ALL AND
FOR THIS REASON CENTERS LIKE
MINE.
I HAVE HAD TO START WAITING
LISTS WHICH WE STARTED FOUR
YEARS AGO.
TODAY WE HAVE FIFTY THREE ON
THAT LIST IN THE AVERAGE WAIT IS
ELEVEN MONTHS.
QUITE OFTEN BY THE TIME WE CALL
THE FAMILY THEIR LOVED ONE HAS
BEEN PLACED IN A NURSING HOME OR
IS PASSED AWAY.
IN THE LAST TWO YEARS THAT THE
CASE FOR THIRTY THREE PEOPLE
THAT RISE TO THE TOP OF THE
WAITING LIST. I'M VERY PROUD OF
THE FACT THAT ARE CENTER
BUILDING NINETEEN EIGHTY FOUR.
WAS BUILT WITH STATE FUNDS OVER
THIS DEPARTMENT AGING.
OF PROVIDED THOSE FUNDS AND WE
WERE THE FIRST BILL TO PURPOSE
ADULT DAY HEALTH CENTER IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. AND IT WAS
BUILT BY A STRONG GROUP OF
COMMUNITY ADVOCATES
SOME OF WHO HAVE AGED AND
ACTUALLY USE OUR PROGRAM.
UNFORTUNATELY THIRTY FOUR YEARS
AGO WE HAD A BIT WE HAVE A
BUILDING THAT IS GROSSLY NINE
EIGHTY A COMPACT COMPLIANCE.
WHETHER ITS ARE DOORWAYS R.
SPRINKLERS R. BATHROOM STALLS
WERE GRANDFATHERED IN BUT NONE
THE LESS WERE NOT A SAFE CENTER.
IN COMPARISON TODAY'S.
CONSTRUCTION WERE OPERATING AT
MAX CAPACITY WE DON'T HAVE
ENOUGH TOILETS OFFICE SPACE AND
WITH ALL THE WHEELCHAIRS AND
WALKERS IT'S TIGHT TIGHT TIGHT.
AND YET WE OPERATE ADULT DAY
HEALTH CARE CENTER AND ADULT
DAYCARE CENTER WHERE EIGHTY CRC
WERE PART OF A COMMUNITY BASED
HEALTH HOME PILOT WE DO SUPPORT
GROUPS AND CAREGIVER WORKSHOPS.
WOOD SO WE NEED TO EXPAND OUR
SPACE BECAUSE OF DEMAND BUT WE
CAN'T RENOVATE OUR CURRENT SITE
WITHOUT HAVING TO INVEST SIX
HUNDRED THOUSAND JUST FOR
RETROFITTING.
THEN WE NEED ADDITIONAL FUNDS
FOR ACTUAL EXPANSION. AN
ENGINEERING FIRM WE HIRED IN TWO
THOUSAND FIFTEEN DETERMINED THAT
FINDING A NEW CENTER LOCATION
THEN TEARING DOWN THE CURRENT
WAS THE BEST. WAY TO GO WELL WE
CAN'T EXACTLY DO THAT.
YET FOR TWO YEARS NOW OUR LOCAL
LEADERS HAVE BEEN TRYING TO
SOLVE THIS PROBLEM WITH LITTLE
PROGRESS DUE TO LACK OF FUNDS.
THE LOSS OF REDEVELOPMENT
DOLLARS WAS A BIG HIT WERE
PLANNING.
FOUNDATIONS DON'T GENERALLY WANT
TO FUND BRICK AND MORTAR.
ENTITIES INVOLVED ARE FEARFUL OF
FINANCING CAPITAL DUE TO
PRECARIOUS FEDERAL HEALTH
COVERAGE HEALTH HEALTHCARE
REFORMS.
AND WE HAVE NOT BEEN ABLE TO
SOLVE THIS PROBLEM DESPITE ALL
THE GAINS FOR THE PEOPLE OF OUR
COUNTY IN THE PAIRS INVOLVED.
IN THIS STATE EXPANSION IS
NEEDED TO MEET THE DEMAND BUT
ALSO TO PROTECT THE CURRENT
CENTERS FROM CLOSING WHEN WE
BILL AND LICENSE OUR PROGRAM IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY FOUR FOR FIFTY
NINE PEOPLE A DAY. YOU COULD
FINANCIALLY BREAK EVEN BY
SERVING ISSUES TWENTY FIVE A
DAY.
THAT'S NOT THE CASE ANYMORE WITH
CURRENT MEDI CAL RATES SO TO BE
FINANCIALLY VIABLE IN OUR
COUNTY.
OUT WE ESTIMATE NEEDING TO SERVE
ONE HUNDRED PER DAY.
IT SOUNDS LIKE A LOT BUT IT'S
THERE SO WE NEED MORE SPACE TO
MEET THE DEMAND AND ALSO TO
AVOID CLOSURES DUE TO.
ONGOING AND NEGATIVE REVENUE
STREAM.
SO THANK YOU FOR LISTENING TO MY
STORY BUT IT'S REALLY OUR STORY
AND WE NEED TO BUILD
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA.
AS WE DON'T GET TO DODGE GROWING
OLD NOR DO WE GET TO DODGE
TAKING CARE OF THE PEOPLE THAT
WE LOVE. SO THE REALITY.
WHICH TO.
ALREADY KNOW IS THAT THE NEED
IS ESCALATING FAST.
AND IF WE DO NOTHING TO GROW THE
NUMBER OF CENTERS IN CALIFORNIA
THE STATE WILL BE PAYING ONE WAY
OR ANOTHER IT THAT JUST A MUCH
HIGHER COST.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
GOOD AFTERNOON. I'M A BARBARA
PART BECAUSE AND THIS IS MY
SISTER BECKY MY KIDS.
AND THIS IS MY MOTHER.
AND WE LIKE TO THINK MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND THE DEVERS FOR
GIVING US THE OPPORTUNITY TO
ADDRESS YOU TODAY.
WE'D ALSO LIKE TO THINK
ASSEMBLYMEMBER.
LENGTH DEIGNED FOR AUTHORING IS
INCREDIBLY SORRY ABOUT THAT A
PORTENT BILL MAHER THAT THAT'S
THAT'S NOT GETTING A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT. WHAT I MEAN POLITICAL
PAYBACK THAT WE REALLY VERY
THANKFUL THAT YOU'RE OFFERING
THIS REALLY INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT
BILL TO ADDRESS A CRITICAL NEED
TO HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
CALIFORNIANS LIVING WITH?
ALZHEIMER'S DISEASE AND THEIR
FAMILIES.
OVER THE TENURE THAT TEN YEARS
AGO MY MOTHER FLORENCE MY MELO
MARQUEZ WAS DIAGNOSED WITH
ALZHEIMER'S TO FEES.
THERE IS SO MUCH TO TELL YOU
ABOUT THIS LONG AND HARD JOURNEY
THAT WE CANTAKE IN HAND IN HAND
WITH ARAB EAST AND HERE'S.
AS YOUR PRIMARY CAREGIVER DO IN
THE LAST FIVE YEARS I CAN SPEAK
VOLUMES ABOUT HER MEDICAL CARE
AS WELL AS THE EMOTIONAL AND
FINANCIAL IMPACT OF THIS
DISEASE.
ON ME MY FAMILY.
BUT MOST GERMANE TO A BEING
FIFTEEN HUNDRED I'D LIKE TO
SHARE THAT MY MOTHER ATTENDED
ADULT MEMORY TAKE CARE PROGRAM
FOR ABOUT THREE YEARS. IT WAS A
TREMENDOUS RESOURCE FOR HER AND
FOR ME IN THE FAMILY.
IT PROVIDERS HER WITH MUCH
NEEDED SOCIALIZATION IN SUPPORT.
IT PERMITTED ME THE ABILITY TO
CONTINUE TO WORK TO HELP SUPPORT
HER AND MOST IMPORTANTLY SHE WAS
ABLE TO STAY HOME. WITH US A
GREATER PERIOD OF TIME.
THERE'S SO MUCH MORE TO TELL YOU
ABOUT THE ARDUOUS JOURNEY
BECAUSE MY ALZHEIMER'S.
BUT I WANNA TAKE THE REST OF MY
TIME TO ACTUALLY TELL YOU ABOUT
MY MOTHER.
AND THE INCREDIBLE LIFE SHE LEAD
BEFORE HER DIAGNOSIS.
SHE AND MY FATHER BUT A SMALL
HOME OFFICE STORY ROAD IN EAST
AND AS A IN THE NINETEEN FIFTIES
NOW KNOWN AS SILICON VALLEY.
BOTH SERVED AS STRONG COMMUNITY
ACTIVISM ON MANY FRONTS.
LIKE FATHER WAS AN ORDAINED
DEACON IN THE CAN IN THE ROMAN
CATHOLIC CHURCH IN MY MOTHER WAS
THE WIFE OF A TICKET. SHE WORKED
IN MANY CAPACITIES SERVING
COMMUNITY NEEDS WHICH REMAINING
IN THE EAST AYE PARISHES OF OUR
LADY Y. LUPE AND MOST HOLY
TRINITY.
SHE WAS ALSO AN EDUCATION
ADVOCATE.
SHE WAS ELECTED AND SERVED AS A
TRUSTEE FOR THE MOUNT PLEASANT
SCHOOL DISTRICT FOR MANY YEARS
AND SHE WAS A FLOP STRONG
PROPONENT OF BILINGUAL
EDUCATION.
SHE PICKETED ALONG SIZE THAT THE
CHARGES AND OFTEN WE WOULD WRITE
LETTERS SIDE TO SUPPORT THE UFW
DURING THE GREAT BOYCOTT. AND
OTHER EVENTS.
SHE SERVED AS PRESIDENT AND
FOUNDING MEMBER OF THE GRAIL
DEVELOPMENT CORPORATION WHICH
BUILD A THIRTY FIVE UNIT
AFFORDABLE HOUSING COMMUNITY.
COMPLETE WITH A LICENSED
HEALTHCARE CENTER AND A WOMAN
CENTER ON THE SAN ANTONIO ROAD.
IT'S WITH THE QUITE IMPRESSIVE
MULTIMILLION DOLLAR PROJECT
ENDEAVOR THAT SHE AND HER FELLOW
GO MILE DAYS BUT TOGETHER. THEY
ACTUALLY RECEIVE THE HOT AWARD
FOR SUCH AN ENDEAVOR.
BECAUSE OF THESE WORKS IN THE
HER MANY OTHER ACCOMPLISHMENTS
SHE WAS RECOGNIZES LEGISLATOR OF
THE YEAR BY FORMER SENATOR JOHN
VASCONCELOS.
YOU THINK IT WILL BE.
YOU MAY CHECK.
JANUARY FIFTH JUST FOUR DAYS
AGO.
I GET UP DIDN'T IT WORDS IS OVER
WE HAVE NO PLACE TO LOOK MY
MOTHER. FLORENCE WHERE KIDS BITS
HERE AND HAD ONE MORE CHANCE TO
BE IN THIS BUILDING.
SHE WOULD BE HERE AT OUR SIDE
AND SHE WOULD ADVOCATE FOR
OTHERS. THOSE ALSO INFLICTED
WITH ALZHEIMER'S AND THEIR
FAMILIES.
AS YOU BE RIGHT HERE AND SHE
WOULD EMPLOYER COULD YOU PLEASE
VOTE IN SUPPORT BABY FIFTEEN
HUNDRED.
AFFORDABLE CULTURALLY COMPETENT
AND ACCESSIBLE SERVICES ARE
NEEDED FOR THE DIVERSE
POPULATION OF THOSE IMPACTED BY
ALZHEIMER'S AND THE FAMILIES
THAT LOVE AND SUPPORT THEM.
THANK YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY.
THANK YOU.
UP OTHER ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
KELLY BROOKS I'M HERE TODAY ON
BEHALF OF THE COUNTY WELFARE
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION WERE VERY
PLEASED TO SUPPORT AB FIFTEEN
HUNDRED.
REBECCA GONZALEZ WITH THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M SUSAN TO
MORRIS ON BEHALF OF THE
ALZHEIMER'S ASSOCIATION WERE
SPONSORS OF THE BILL AND WERE
PLEASE TO SUPPORT TODAY.
NANCY MIRISCH ON BEHALF OF THE
CONGRESS OF CALIFORNIA SENIORS
IN SUPPORT.
CAROL SUL FROM THE CALIFORNIA
COMMISSION ON AGING I JUST
WANTED TO THANK ASSEMBLYMEMBER
MAIENSCHEIN FOR CARRYING THIS
VERY IMPORTANT MEASURE. AND JUST
TO SAY THAT AS THE DAUGHTER OF
SOMEONE WHO LIVED IN SISKIYOU
COUNTY. AND DEVELOPED
ALZHEIMER'S AT A TIME WHEN. ALL
THE SERVICES HAD BEEN ELIMINATED
AND THEY WERE MEAGER BEFORE.
.
KNOWING THAT WE HAD TO PUT MY
MOTHER INTO AN R. CFE BECAUSE
THERE WAS NO HELP FOR MY SISTER
WHO LIVED WITH HER.
IT'S IT IS HEARTBREAKING AND IT
IS HEARTBREAKING AND I FEEL YOUR
PAIN.
THINK.
YES DEREK HELT WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF AREA
AGENCIES ON AGING WE ARE AWESOME
SUPPORT.
HI LYDIA MISSILE LEVI'S
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION FOR ADULT
DAY SERVICES OUR CONDOLENCES TO
YOU BOTH.
A MY FATHER DIED WITHOUT TIMERS
DISEASE. FEWER THAN ONE HUNDRED
YEARS OLD TODAY IS HIS BIRTHDAY
SO I FEEL LIKE THAT'S A SIGNAL.
THAT THIS BILL IS GOING TO DO
WELL.
AND I I JUST WANTED TO SAY TO
MY COULD HAVE SAID ANYTHING
BETTER THAN MY COLLEAGUE AND
FRIEND ON SAID.
BUT I WANTED TO ALSO ADD THAT
WE FIELD PHONE CALLS.
ALMOST EVERYDAY NOW IT'S IT'S
ACCELERATING FROM CONSUMERS AND
LEFT WILL OF FAMILY LOVED ONES
LOOKING FOR HELP.
AND IT REALLY BREAKS MY HEART
WHEN I HAVE TO TELL THEM THERE
IS NOTHING NOTHING IN DRIVING
DISTANCE OF WHERE YOU LIVE OR
YOUR LOVED ONE LIVES.
AND WE TRY TO OFFER THEM SOME
OTHER ALTERNATIVES BUT IT'S.
THE NEED IS THERE AND WE NEED
TO GET AHEAD OF THIS AGING CURVE
AND WE APPRECIATE.
YOUR LEADERSHIP ON THIS THANK
YOU.
ANY WHO OF IT ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION.
OKAY SO AS WE BRING ABOUT ONE TO
START I THINK COUPLE YOU CAME IN
AFTER WE BEGAN A ONE A REITERATE
MY THANKS TO SIGN MEMBER. GLORIA
AND GIPSON UP FOR EUROPE. YOU
AND YOUR STAFF HELP ON THE
HEARINGS WE HAD INCENDIO LOS
ANGELES AS WELL AS OUR VICE
CHAIRS ATTENDANCE. OF THE
HEARING AND SAN DIEGO I FOUND
THEM TO BE VERY PRODUCTIVE IN
THAT WOULD HAVE BEEN POSSIBLE
WITHOUT YOUR HELP SO THANK YOU.
AND.
.
THE SAME OUR THINKING WAS AND
THE BILL AND I WANT TO START BY
SAYING FORUMS MARQUEZ.
IS HERE SHOULD BE VERY PROUD OF
THE TO YOU FOR BEING HERE FOR
DAYS AFTER A PASSING ANALYSIS
HAS TWO AMAZING DAUGHTERS.
OTHER THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE
FOR ADVOCATING I'M.
IT YOU COULD BE ANYWHERE ELSE WE
PART WOULD EXPECTED TO BE
SOMEWHERE ELSE.
BUT BEING HERE MEANS A LOT NINE
AND I THINK THAT YOUR MOTHER
WOULD BE VERY PROUD THINKING.
AND BUG THE SAME MEMBER A
COUPLE THINGS BEFORE I PASS IT
OVER TO MY COLLEAGUES ONE IS.
THEIR DESIRED DATE SPECIFIED
BUT ABOUT UNDERSTANDING IS THAT
IT WOULD LIKELY BE TWENTY TWENTY
IS THAT WHAT THEY'RE ACT. OKAY.
THE OTHER THING IS THAT I I
BELIEVE THAT AS OF TODAY THERE
HASN'T YET BEEN A STATE AGENCY
IDENTIFIED THAT SOME BUT YOU'RE
ALSO WORKING ON THAT THAT'S
CORRECT AS WELL.
OKAY AS OF NOW JUST KIND OF
TENTATIVELY WE HAVE THE STATE'S
TREASURES UP SORT OFIN THERE
BUT WERE STILL WORKING TO FIND
THE APPROPRIATE.
AGENCY THAT WILL DO THAT OKAY.
I'M OF ONE OF THE THINGS THAT OF
A BONDS OF THE STAGE I KNOW
PRIOR BOND THAT WAS TO LEARN
THIS NATURE PARTICULARLY REGARDS
TO. THE CONSTRUCTION OF OF OR
OF.
BUT I UPGRADING OF FACILITIES
TYPICALLY REQUIRES OR HAS WITH
THAT A PREVAILING WAGE
REQUIREMENT AND IS THAT
SOMETHING THAT. AS THIS MOVES
FORWARD THAT YOU'LL BE WORKING
ON INCLUDING YES WE WILL THAT
WILL BE INCLUDED WHICH.
EXCELLENT THANK YOU AND THEN.
THE OTHER THING IS BECAUSE I
AND I DID.
YOU KNOW. IT IN MY.
LAST YEAR IN IN MY ROLE HERE
I'VE LEARNED A LOT ABOUT
FINANCIAL EMOTIONAL. MENTAL
STRAIN OF CAREGIVERS AND
PARTICULARLY THOSE THAT HAVE
LOVED ONES.
SUFFERING WITH ALZHEIMER'S AND
I'M A HUGE FAN I DON'T TAKE IT
DAY CENTERS ABOUT OPPORTUNITY TO
CHECK OUT THE ONE IN SAN JOSE
IT'S IT'S PHENOMENAL AND I WOULD
LOVE TO SEE THE EXPANSION. OF
THOSE TYPES OF SERVICES OB OVER
THE ONE THING IN TERMS OF
THIS-PARTICULAR.
BILL BUT IT WOULD BE FRANKLY
EVEN SEE IF THERE ARE OTHER
OPPORTUNITIES FOR SYNERGY WITH
OTHER TYPES OF SERVICE I MEAN IT
REALLY JUST EXPANDING IT MAKING
A LARGER. PACKAGE AND THAT'S NOT
SOMETHING THAT'S BY MORE
PUBLICLY DISCUSSED YOU OFFLINE
BY THE RIGHT NOW BUT JUST TO.
KEEP IN MIND THAT THE YOU KNOW
I'VE ONE THING I'VE LEARNED
THOSE LAST TWO THERE'S SO MUCH.
THERE THERE ARE SO MANY ISSUES
WHEN IT COMES TO LONG TERM CARE
WHEN IT COMES TO CARING. FOR
AFFRONT LOVELAND'S WITH WITH
WHAT IT COMES AND SO THERE MAY
BE AN OPPORTUNITY AND THAT ALSO
COULD POTENTIALLY HELP IN TERMS
OF BRINGING THE LARGER
COALITION.
BUT JUST WELL A VERY GENERAL
THOUGHT FOR YOU THINK ABOUT AND
I'D BE HAPPY TO TALK TO ME MORE
ABOUT IT IS TO GO FAVORITE.
I'M THINK YOU VERY MUCH FOR FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD AND.
OUR CONDOLENCES TO THE MARKETS
FAMILY AND THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE.
GOTTA BE A DIFFICULT TIME TO
SHOW UP AT THE CAPITOL BUT I
WOULD AGREE WITH OUR CHAIR. ON
YOUR MOTHER'S HERE WITH US AND I
THINK WE ALL ARE LOOKING OUT FOR
THE SAME. IT IT REALLY IS A
TSUNAMI ON THIS DISEASE IS A
HORRIBLE DISEASE ON AND THE MORE
THAT WE CAN CREATE OPPORTUNITIES
FOR. ON. FOR THE INDIVIDUALS
THAT ARE ARE GOING THROUGH THE
EXPERIENCE TO ACTUALLY HAVE SOME
CARE. THAT. NO UNDERSTANDS THE
DISEASE AND CAN HELP THEM.
IS IS REALLY IMPORTANT SO I I
HAVE A COUPLE OF SUGGESTIONS AND
THERE ARE A MENACE SUPPORT THE
BILL I I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
I'M GLAD TO HEAR THAT. THE CHAIR
TALK ABOUT MAYBE I AM INCLUDING
SOME OTHER SERVICES AND MAY BE
MAKING IT A LITTLE BIT BIGGER.
I'M A COUPLE OF THINGS ONE IS.
.
IS RIGHT NOW THE WAY IT'S
WRITTEN THE MONEY WOULD GO TO
THE STATE DEPARTMENT TO
ADMINISTER.
AND IT WOULD IT WOULD BE. IT
IPS.
GENERALLY BASED ON THE NEED IN
THE COMMUNITY AND THE FACT THAT
THERE ARE SOME COMMUNITIES THAT
HAVE VERY LITTLE SERVICES RIGHT
QUITE FRANKLY THOSE ARE RURAL
COMMUNITIES.
IN RURAL COMMUNITIES THERE ARE
NO SERVICES IN AND MANY.
BUT BUT THE CHALLENGE WITH
DOING A GRANT PROPOSAL WHERE
IT'S A COMP COMPETITIVE GRANT.
IS THAT THAT JURISDICTION HAS TO
HIRE A GRANT WRITER. THE STATE
HAS TO HIRE A GRANT RIVER
REVIEWER AND IT'S USUALLY STAFF
BUT IT COSTS MONEY. AND SO
ADMINISTRATION ENDS UP TAKING A
CHUNK.
AND SO IT MAY MAKE SENSE FOR
THIS TO BE SET UP SO THAT THE
MONEY GOES DIRECTLY TO THE
COUNTIES.
BECAUSE THEY'RE THE ONES THAT
ARE ACTUALLY CAN ADMINISTER THE
PROGRAMS. AND.
AND I PERSONALLY HATE THAT THAT
THE ALLOCATION BASED ON.
.
ON.
POPULATION BECAUSE IN THE RURAL
COUNTIES GET VERY LITTLE BUT
THERE MAY BE THERE THERE HAVE
BEEN SOME FORMULAS DEVELOPED
THAT.
THAT TAKES POPULATION INTO
CONSIDERATION BUT ALSO MAYBE
TAKE THAT FACT THAT SOME OF THE
RURAL COUNTIES ARM HAVE NO
SERVICES AND YOU MIGHT BE ABLE
TO BOOST IT SO WHAT I'M
SUGGESTING IS. IS RATHER THAN
SETTING IT UP AS A STATE
COMPETITIVE PROGRAM THAT THERE
BE A WAY TO GET IT STRAIGHT TO
THE LOCALS.
THE TREASURES DEPARTMENT
DOESN'T HAVE THAT. KNOWLEDGE OR
OR THAT THE BASE OF INFORMATION
THAT THE CARE PROVIDERS HABIT IN
REGARDS TO WHAT THE MARKET MOST
APPROPRIATE SERVICES.
AND MOST APPROPRIATE.
.
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT SHOULD BE IN
PLACE WHEN YOU'RE HERE DEALING
WITH SENIORS WITH MEMORY ISSUES
AND HEALTH CARE ISSUES SO I'M
I'M JUST SUGGESTING THAT THERE
MAY BE IT A DIFFERENT WAY TO DO
IT. THAT'LL MAKE IT GET TO THE
PEOPLE WHO REALLY ARE GOING TO
BE ABLE TO START. BUILDING AND
OFFERING THE SERVICES AS QUICKLY
AS POSSIBLE. DOT THAT WAS MY.
.
MIGHT. YOU KNOW AS I LOOKED AT
HOW OPERATIONALLY YOU YOU HAD IT
SET UP THE TREASURE IS GOING TO
BE CONVENING AND DOING THINGS
WHICH MEANS IT'LL BE A GOOD.
FIVE YEARS BEFORE ANY MONEY
ROLLS OUT EVEN ONCE IT'S PAST
AND IF THERE'S A DIFFERENT WAY
TO DO IT AND SEND IT EITHER
THROUGH THE COUNTY OFFICE OF
AGING OR THE COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS YOU MAY BE ABLE TO
GET IT OUT QUICKER AND. AND
ACTUALLY HAVE.
THOSE LOCAL ORGANIZATIONS TRYING
TO FIGURE OUT WHAT WOULD BE BELT
OF WE'RE GOING TO BUILD
SOMETHING THAT DARK THEY CAN
ALREADY DEPEND ON SOME MONEY
GOING THERE AND NOT HAVE TO.
HOPE THAT THEY GET THE GRANT.
FIVE YEARS DOWN THE ROAD SO.
BECOMES
SARAH GIBSON.
I WANT TO SAY TO THE MARKETS
FAMILY THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
ONE BEING HERE I THINK YOU
EXHIBIT. A GREAT.
COURAGE.
NOTHING'S A TESTAMENT IN TERMS
OF.
YOUR MISSION YOUR QUEST TO.
TO BE PROACTIVE IN THIS AREA.
I FOR ONE MY FATHER HAD IT AND
AS A RESULT PASSED AWAY.
OF IT AND.
CERTAINLY REALIZE HOW IMPORTANT
THIS YEAR'S AND CERTAINLY WANT
TO JOIN IN AND AND IN THIS
PARTICULAR MISSION. AND WE OFFER
OUR SERVICES TO MEMBER MAIN SIGN
IF YOU WOULD BE SO INCLINED TO
OF ADD ME AS A CO AUTHOR I WOULD
CERTAINLY LOVE TO COOPER THIS
BILL. AND LOOK FOR TO WORK WITH
YOU AND ALSO DON'T WE NEED DO
NOT AGREE WITH MY. COLLEAGUE I
THINK THE COUNTY WILL BE THE.
APPROPRIATE.
AREA WHICH THE RESOURCES CAN BE
FOLLOWED THE RULE INSTEAD OF.
STATE AGENCY GETS KINDA.
BOGGED UP BLOCKER SEE IN THINGS
OF THAT NATURE WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE WE ARE EXPEDIENT. AS WELL
REALLY RELATES TO I'M RESOURCES
GIVING TO.
THE MOST OF NEEDS OF
ORGANIZATIONS TO HELP FACILITATE
THESE KINDS OF PROGRAMS SO.
I'M EXCITED ABOUT IT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU. UP BY SEVERAL.
IT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN.
SO.
MAIENSCHEIN KNOWS.
THAT I'M A TIGHTWAD.
I DON'T VOTE FOR HARDLY ANY
MONEY.
ANY TIME ANYWHERE.
I WILL SUPPORT THIS A TELL YOU
WHY BECAUSE.
I'M LOOKING AT HERE IN THE YEAR
TWENTY SIXTY.
SENIORS ARE PROJECTED TO PRESENT
TWENTY FOUR PERCENT.
OR ONE IN FOUR OF CALIFORNIA
POPULATION.
I WILL BE A HUNDRED AND TWELVE
YEARS OLD YEAH.
SO I'M WAY FOR THIS. THAT.
I GOTTA HAVE SOME FUN.
SO.
THE VOTERS OF CALIFORNIA.
WILL VOTE OR NOT VOTE FOR TWO
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS OF A
BOND ISSUE.
AND STRANGELY ENOUGH IS A TYPE
HiA AND THE.
VERY FISCALLY CONSERVATIVE
CONSERVATIVE.
IT SEEMS THAT MOST PARENTS GET
PAST.
BECAUSE THE MAJORITY OF THE
CALIFORNIA VOTERS DON'T REALLY
FIGURE THEIR PAIN FAR.
SERIOUSLY.
THEY FIGURE THE RICH PEOPLE ARE
PAYING HIM FAR AT WHICH IS
BASICALLY TRUE.
SO.
I WOULD GO ON.
RECORD.
WITH MY CHAIRMAN TO SUPPORT
THIS.
.
AND I FIND IT INTERESTING THAT
MY COLLEAGUE.
FROM SAN DIEGO.
HAS.
PUT IN.
WORDING.
WITHOUT REGARD TO FISCAL YEARS.
THAT'S REALLY SMART.
YOU'RE A SMART GUY
THAT WAS GOOD.
BECAUSE WE'RE GOING TO GO INTO
ANOTHER RECESSION.
SO YOUR WORDING IS WITHOUT
REGARD TO FISCAL YEARS SO THAT
I'LL ALLOCATION GOES NO MATTER
WHAT.
SIR.
I'M GOING.
THINK YOU BASE YOUR.
WE DO HAVE A MOTION ANY OTHER
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM THE
MEMBERS.
ALRIGHT IF WE CAN DO OF OAK ON
THE BOAT.
KALRA.
I.
KALRA AYE BOVELL.
NOVELL AYE. CABALLERO. CAVIAR
AYE GIPSON AYE GIPSON AYE
GLORIA.
GLORIA AYE MELENDEZ. MELINDA'S
AYE RUBIO.
RUBIO I TO MEASURES OUT. EXCEL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
CREDIBLE IN HERE.
THE MEETINGS ADJOURNED